today we are going to learn about white
comedy is funny and how to use humor to
make yourself rich and famous well
alright are you poppy welcome to my show
I love you it I'm going to be able to
write a hilarious bit because this
random situation good tie my favorite
part about comedy because they're a
perfect way to tell jokes what's your
best day oh my best set I have one about
going to adjust the Bieber concert he
makes everyone pray with Justin Bieber
is a celebrity and if you talk about
celebrities more people will think
you're funny
why and it really thought about it like
that papi I'm going to tell more jokes
about famous celebrities that I too will
be a famous celebrity the truth is most
people have nothing to say and because
of that most people are unbelievably
boring papi I love your videos because
they make my brain feel funny
I Love You Brandon I love you too papi I
love doing post and going viral I love
all of you
[Music]
you